j'en ai pas parlé mais ça grince plus
nouvelles chaises aucun grincement aucun
toujours aucun fantastique ou pas nous
avons tous eu une enfance joyeuse avec
des parents qu'ils s'occupaient de nous
j'espère et surtout beaucoup de parties
de jeux de société et de moments de jeu
avec des jouets jouer j'ai une
discussion il ya pas longtemps avec des
potes on reparlait un peu déjoué notre
enfance et en vrai c'était un pote qui
est 50 plus vieux au plus jeune que toi
et ben les jouets qu'il y avait dans son
enfance peuvent être très différentes
des tiens on dirait pas mais cinq ans
d'écart ça fait que la mode à l'époque
dans la cour de récré n'est plus la même
par exemple moi j'avais eu des jo jo ce
mais en fait c'était surtout la mode
comme mon frère qui a 5 ans et demi de
plus que moi était à l'école primaire
bref je voulais retrouver un peu tous
les jeux qu'on a eu donc ceux qui sont
nés en 94 15 16 17 on va dire qu'on a
tous eu le tamagotchi on a tous eu vent
de trois cartes pokémon normal on a tous
fait du pen spinning avec nos stylos
c'était fou rigolez pas et en fait on
faisant des recherches j'ai réalisé que
comme je suis tombé très très tôt dans
les jeux vidéo bah je suis passé à côté
de plein plein de jouets styles et les
genres vraiment la machine belgique par
exemple pour faire ses propres badge
c'était stylet mais je n'ai pas eu alors
que j'avais à l'époque qu'il avait bref
on a pas retracé tous les jouets
inquiétait être qu'on était plus jeune
et c'est pas le sujet de la vidéo c'est
juste qu'en faisant ses recherches j'ai
découvert qu'il ya des jouets de malades
mais genre vraiment dangereux de fou à
tel point qu'ils ont été interdits à tel
point qu'ils ont fait des blessés voire
des décès en fait pour moi ces gens
évident que les trucs qu'on vend et qui
sont à destination des enfants ils
doivent être genre quand ils sortent
hyper béton il doit y avoir aucun risque
pour l'enfant de se blesser ou au caire
à quelques trucs négatifs qu'ils
puissent se passer à cause du jouet ou
du jeu et mais qu'il ya des trucs qui
sont passés et qui sont sortis mais qui
sont juste scandaleux et je la fasse ça
n'a aucun sens en fait j'ai eu la même
prise de conscience que quand j'ai
découvert toute l'histoire autour de
action parc où je suis mais comment
c'est possible d'avoir fait des trucs
aussi dangereux et que personne n'ait
rien dit pendant aussi longtemps c'est
dingue
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
quelques-uns de ses jouets et on
commence avec un pack pour souffler du
verre voilà directement celui là ils
datent pas du tout des années 90 où 80
ils datent des années 50
voilà donc c'est pardonné à moitié mais
ça me tue qu'à l'époque des gaz soit dit
cette activité extrêmement dangereux
qu'est de souffle et du verre on va
faire un petit pack pour rendre ça
accessible aux enfants c'est bien ça
comme il est dans la même mine il y
avait un truc encore plus dangereux qui
est le jouet dangereux le plus connu de
tous les temps c'est le atomic energy
l'abe et en gros c'était un petit kit
pour que ton enfant il puisse faire des
expériences chimiques est dedans il y
avait du minerai dangereux il y avait du
plomb du zinc du ruthénium et même du
polonium donc c'est des trucs
radioactifs mais à très faible dose mais
ça n'a rien à faire entre les mains d'un
enfant est dans le kit avait même un
compteur geiger pour mesurer la
radioactivité
c'est fou ils en ont fabriqué 5000 du
coup que pendant deux ans et du coup
maintenant c'est un paquet genre méga
collector bref à l'époque c'était
vraiment à la mode de vendre à des
petits garçons des coffrets qui te
permettent de faire des trucs que papa
fait à l'usiné mais pas en version jour
nul en mode plastique inoffensif non non
il ya eu un kit du mini bricoleur depuis
les années 2000 l'équipe du mini
bricoleur savez le genre des fausses
perceuse en plastique ont juste qui font
juste le bruit de la perceuse
là ça fait vraiment tout comme les
instruments de papa quand je vous dis
que c'est la même chose en plus petits
c'est que c'est vrai ça fonctionne
pareil jean tassy sauteuse c'est
vraiment une scie sauteuse elle est plus
petite que celle de papa mais c'est une
scie sauteuse parfait pour que titouan
en cassette ans et demi se blesse en
fait ça me tue la mentalité à l'époque
c'est de se dire bon on va faire la même
en plus petit et c'est ok ça passe et
moins dangereux un truc qui a toujours
fait kiffer les enfants c'est les
pistolets on adore regarder nerf quel
plaisir de tirer sur son amie une
fléchette sans qu'ils n'aient la moindre
égratignure mais ça n'a pas toujours été
comme ça moi quand j'avais 8 ans n'y
avait pas de nerfs il y avait des
pistolets dans lesquels tu mettais les
espèces de rondelles en plastique là et
ça faisait juste du bruit gens en vrai
nom mais vraiment les gars à tous ceux
qui ont eu un franchement vous avez fait
péter deux rondelles et flemme après
flavie
[Musique]
du coup les plus faibles d'entre nous
trouvait un petit moyen de se procurer
un gain nabi ski et mélia dangereux et
ben écoutez en 1940
on va venir attendait 6 des terres d by
day a aidé à presque 100 piges
on arrive à déjouer beaucoup plus
récente très bientôt il avait créé
l'ancêtre du nerf et du cannabis
et ça s'appelait le austin magic
pistoles alors comme les autres il s'est
fait pas des magasins évidemment mais
les mecs avaient compris que ce qui
faisait qui fait les enfants c'était le
bruit quand tu tires et le fait qu'un
truc partent vraiment du pistolet sig
lauber le projectile c'était une balle
de ping pong et elles étaient propulsés
grâce à du carbure de calcium qui est un
produit chimique qui une fois mélangés à
de l'eau à une réaction explosive de ouf
à tel point que ça crée une petite boule
de feu à la sortie du bis ça me tue en
vrai je suis un peu jaloux
j'aurais adoré l'avoir étant plus jeune
c'est plus de mon âge elle aime bien
évidemment il ya eu jean vila les
enfants blessés à cause du jet de flamme
que ça fait en fait il ya eu des
brûlures il ya eu des soucis aussi aux
oreilles puisque ça fait un gros bruit
et quand il tirait que les oreilles
train bref ça a été ban directement se
jouer les années 50-60 c'était
clairement un autre game au niveau des
jouets vendus aux enfants c'était fou
déjà chaque fois je veux être comme ça
ça me fait penser à fallout
ça me fait kiffer au fond je me dis
[ __ ] ces années là ont vraiment existé
en fait the swing wing c'est un jeu
sorti en 1965 j'ai rien à dire vous
allez tout comprendre
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu as l'air quand je
comprends même pas le plaisir n'est même
pas de challenge à faire ça quand un
ruban est attaché à ton crâne surfer du
hula hoop là comme s'était petit il ya
un petit challenge parce qu'il faut être
genre synchro faut être fort et tout
pour que le truc tournée reste au niveau
de la taille
mais là y'a aucun challenge évidemment
que tu fais ça le truc va tourner parce
qu'il est attaché à ton casque est en
moi j'irai à sketches et tu te mets
toutes les situations possibles genre
c'est agréable à faire quand tu fais des
barres parallèles
berkshire que dans ce genre c'est la
grande affaire quand et embarque un
endroit où tu as déjà là j avoue sans
même avoir à faire ça avec ta tête ça
sortait aujourd'hui tout le monde ferait
mes mecs ça n'a aucun intérêt et puis
c'est dangereux tu en train d'inciter
les gens à secouer leur tête dans tous
les sens pendant des heures juste pour
faire bouger un [ __ ] de ruban ça
suffit bien évidemment ce jouet il a été
banni très peu de temps après sa sortie
parce qu'il ya eu énormément de
blessures au niveau du cou parce que
tous les enfants s'amusaient à faire ça
sauf qu'ils se [ __ ] le coup en plus
avoir l'air d'être coincé je trouve je
trouve ça fou je vous parle de jouets
qui sont sortis dans les années 40-50
n'y a pas encore trop de lois et de
régulation par contre dans les années
80-90 c'est quand même bien plus tard on
est presque cinquante ans plus tard et
on s'imagine qu'entre temps il ya eu un
vrai effort et y a plus jamais eu de
scandale autour de jouer qui causaient
des blessures voire des morts n'est ce
pas laissez moi vous parler des mots
choses déjà acquis elles font envie
donnez-moi le pistolet life et des
flammes c'est un jeu qui est sorti au
début des années 90 et franchement qui
sur le papier
tudou marketing mais en parlant c'est
fort ça s'appelle et munchhouse parce qu
apparemment ça reproduit l'association
que les astronautes ont lorsqu'ils
marchent sur la lune
ces parias déjà c'était un enfer pour
les parents parce que c'est une boîte en
plastique sous la chaussure et cette
boîte
elle se lève et à leurs intérêts sur la
répétition mais du coup quand un enfant
il n'en fait pas sur de l'herbe ou sur
un tapis
autre vrai gros problème c'est
clairement fait pour tu te pète la
cheville comme n'y a pas de maintien au
niveau de la cheville il ya là les
enfants qui sont foulés voir casser la
cheville mais ça n'a pas été bonne non
alors que clairement genre y'a rien de
sécurisant après peut-être que j'ai la
mentalité d'un papa poule qui
s'inquiètent pour rien vis-à-vis des
enfants
peut-être dans ce cas là laissez moi
vous parler de akwa dot là vous allez
bien la ferme et aqua dotz est sorti en
vous et moi on aurait pu acheter à quoi
d'autre en vrai c'est un jouet coulon en
gros t'es une grille sur laquelle tu
place des boules et sous cette grille tu
peux mettre un calque donc en gros tu
peux arriver un dessin trop stylé grâce
au calcul est en dessous en n'ayant
aucun sens artistique et ensuite à
l'aide d'un spray magix à l'école les
unes aux autres et tu obtiens une sorte
de figurines quoi un vrai truc en 3d
perso je trouve ça génial ce genre
minecraft irl sauf que il ya plein
d'enfants qui ont ingéré les fameuses
petites boules que tu place pour former
le dessin de ton choix combien de fois
on a eu le message sur des bijoux et
même dans ton happy meal
attention il ya plein de petits bouts
qui se détache faites gaffe à ce que
votre enfant ils ingèrent pas bhl la
plein d'enfants ont ingéré et le blème
c'est que dans cette boule
donc ce ne sont que des produits
chimiques vous en doutez et parmi ces
produits chimiques
il y en a un qui s'apparente à du ghb
c'est bon le ghb c'est la drogue du viol
d'ailleurs fait attention à vauvert en
soirée très important c'est un truc qui
est indolore qui est incolore selon la
dose ingérée
c'est plus ou moins violents il ya
nausées vomissements confusion mentale
et ça peut aller jusqu'à la détresse
respiratoire et le coma du coup il ya
des mamans qui avant d'aller travailler
laisser leurs enfants faire des petits
dessins sur à quoi d'autre parce qu'ils
viennent de la voir à noël tout mimi et
quand elle rentrait le gamin était dans
le coma alors rassurez-vous n'y a pas eu
de mort et vous en doutez le jouet a été
palme du marché littéralement et la même
été ricol savez quand un truc est en
vente et qu'il est d'effectuer tout la
marque fait ce qu'on appelle un rappel
donc tous les gens qui l'ont acheté sont
appelés à le ramener il se font
rembourser et ils ont rappelé 4,2
millions d'ha quoi d'autre et ça je vous
rappel c'est en 2007 ce genre vraiment
récent il est temps de parler des laumes
d'arte
la photo est trompeuse ça fait pas du
tout cette taille ça fait cette taille
c'est bon pour vous le budget il est
assez classique ça s'apparente genre à
la pétanque ou aux palets bretons ou à
tous les jeux ou en gros tu dois lancer
un truc le plus près d'un objectif
sauf que là ce que tu l'a lancé c'est
une énorme fléchettes avec un bout en
métal de plusieurs centimètres en plus
ils disent fléchettes c'est trompeur
fléchettes on s'imagine à un tout petit
truc qu'on doit lancer sur une cible la
serbie
énorme truc qui peut faire des très
grandes distances il ya des vidéos de
mecs qui en envoie plus de 30 mètres sur
youtube de ça alors le jeu est sorti
dans les années 50 et dans les années 70
il a failli se faire battre mais les
fabricants ont réussi à négocier auprès
de la commission de la sécurité des
produits et ils ont obtenu le simple
fait que ce ne soit plus en vente à
jouéclub toys'r'us
mais ça n'a pas suffi puisque entre
janvier 78 et décembre 86 ya eu plus de
6000 enfants qui sont allés aux urgences
à cause de blessures liées à ces énormes
fléchettes
malheureusement sur ces milliers de
blessés il ya eu deux décès et du coup
en 88 la commission a revoté est le
jouet a été banni définitivement de tous
les magasins ce qui semble plutôt
logique a mal joué d'époque c'est le cri
pis crawler qui avait pour le coup une
vraiment une bonne pub
ça fait envie ou pas franchement ça fait
envie moi je veut coller mes petits
trucs sur les lunettes de papa et le
faire peur j'adore le souci c'est
qu'avant d'en arriver à faire ton un sac
multicolore il faut donc mettre du
produit chimique dans un moule et
semoule le mettre dans un fourre tout
est intégré dans le pack
c'est pas genre papa qui le met dans le
four pour toi ce truc c'est un four qui
monte à 140 9 degrés c'est bon et on
fait des enfants de mme été leakée
dedans il mettait la plaque dans le four
sauf qu'ils pouvaient sortir le truc du
four avant la fin de la cuisson et
surtout avant que tout est refroidie et
donc du coup il ya eu là les enfants qui
sont brûlés puis ils ont touché la
plaque à la sortie du four
et en plus de ça pendant que c'était en
cuisson comme c'est des produits
chimiques sa dégager des vapeurs
toxiques pas bonne du tout pour la santé
encore une fois c'est clairement adressé
aux petits-enfants quoi genre c'est ça
que je trouve fou qui se souvient de
magnetix c'était un jouet on voit avec
des boules aimanté et des sticks et tu
pouvais faire toutes formes d'objets et
s'était du coup un jeu de construction
un peu comme les cap là où tu pouvais
faire plein de figure grâce à toutes les
boules et athée stick aimante et ça a
été ban
je savais pas ça m'a fait un truc
d'apprendre ça parce que mec la pub elle
passait partout tout le temps et je me
souviens tous mes potes il avait ça et
ben ça a été battre parce qu'il ya plein
d'enfants qui ont avalé les petites
boucles magnétiques c'est toujours la
même histoire souvent c'est des trucs
que les enfants ingèrent et qui sont
vraiment pas bon pour la santé
ou alors cédé four à 150 degrés à ne
jouer comme ça qui est sorti en 2007
c'est le cs fingerprint examination kit
qui s'en souvient je sais pas s'il y
avait une pub ou quoi mais ce jouet me
dis un truc je suis sûr de l'avoir vu
pas mal de fois il m'a dit moi c'est
trop stylé j'aimerais trop la boire bref
c'est un kit d' enquête ou en gros tu
devais relevé des fausses empreintes
digitales les examiner et serra et tu
prenais grand pour un gars de ncis
sauf que dans le kit avait une poudre à
base d'amiante l'un des matériaux les
plus dangereux pour la santé directement
sacré des cancers de la pellicule qui
entourent tes poumons et surtout quand
elles étaient exposés à de l'amiante
c'est que 20 ans après que ça se déclare
et donc là il te vends des impacts pour
enfin dans lequel il y avait de
l'amiante je trouve ça incroyable dès
les années 80 aussi c'était la folie des
cabbage patch versus je connaissais pas
ces découpes et qui ont cette gueule
alors j'avoue j'ai trop stylé là
maintenant que j'ai 24 ans avait
peut-être que à cet enjeu les aurait
trouvés un peu moins stylé et un peu
plus effrayant
quoi qu'il en soit en 95 et sorte une
version de cette poupée qui est
incroyable parce que tu peux la nourrir
mais vraiment la nourrir c'est à dire il
ya des sticks de bouffe et quand tu lui
mets dans la bouche elle le mange genre
elle elle absorbe peu à peu le stick de
bouffe comme si elle le manger et il est
réutilisable puisqu'il se retrouve en
fait dans son abdomen et donc tout
l'abdomen tu récupères lutic lui donne à
bouffer à l'infini elle a l'air ouf on
est d'accord
eh ben ils ont merdé sur un truc en fait
le moteur qui a dans la bouche tu peut
pas l'arrêter
y'a pas de fonction d'urgence ou genre
quand il ya trop de résistance il
s'arrête le souci c'est que les enfants
ils ont commencé à lui faire manger des
crayons papier des stylos des bâtons ils
ont commencé à mettre leurs doigts dans
la bouche leurs cheveux et du coup il ya
eu ce genre là les blessés et ses palmes
directement ils ont dû en rappeler 500
1000 mhz parce que vous savoir que
c'était vraiment genre un truc méga hype
à l'époque ces poupées là et là c'était
le modèle le plus dingue de tout quoi
honnêtement je suis à deux doigts d'en
acheter une ce que genre si les
premières poupées que je vois que je
trouve pas effrayante en fait parce qu
elles se veulent pas réaliste elles
veulent juste sympathique jeu en train
de juger des poupées ok ok on va finir
avec un truc culte les sky dancers vous
souvenez pas des skylanders c'est l'un
des jouets vraiment jouer les plus hype
de tous les temps ils en ont vendu des
palettes et des palettes et surtout il
ya eu la vidéo la plus drôle du web avec
une skin heads up radio là dans la vidéo
c'est une version automatisée avec un
lanceur et tout comme le hibou de seb
ces genres incroyable à l'époque tu
tires et une fille c'est le même
mécanisme que les beyblade extra vous
connaissez sauf qu'en fait les ailes de
la poupée soit en plastique genre très
solide et tombent très très vite du coup
il ya eu ce genre des blessures graves à
l'oeil des dents cassées des bosses sur
le crâne et où ils ont dû agir et ils
ont dû en rappelé huit millions 900
mille mais elle a échappé aux bad s'en
est bien sorti cinq assortis et bien
écoutez c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur
tous ses vieux jouets en fait je suis en
train de qui fait découvrir des trucs du
passé passé et de comprendre qu'il ya eu
des évolutions de malades en fait c'est
un peu bas tout ce que je dis mais pour
moi ça me semblait genre inconcevable
genre c'est vraiment une blague qui te
vendent des fléchettes géantes qui ont
transpercé des enfants fin je trouve ça
fou c'est comme pour à john parkes en
fait j'ai l'impression que il ya
toujours eu des lois qui encadrent est
parfaitement les choses mais en fait pas
du tout et c'est encore plus choquant
c'est aussi le cas pour des trucs qui
sont destinés aux enfants
voilà tout ce qu'on veut c'est jouer
bravo vous
être bien sorti apparemment bravo je
m'en vais souffler du verre j'adorerais
vraiment ce pas que j'aurais adoré la
boîte dangereux ou pas j'aurais c'est un
truc j'aurais kiffé allez je vous dis à
bientôt filet à l'efi les filets
[Musique]
on